I got started in comedy through
necessity because what I would say it's
because I had always wanted to do comedy
even from a very young age I liked
trying to make people laugh from primary
school really I worked out that that was
a way of getting me the attention I
seemed to crave so I like trying to make
people laugh so I think it was always at
the back of my mind
and then I didn't quite have the courage
of my convictions I did a drama course
at university and largely just played
comedy roles throughout and then at the
end of university I ran away and became
a teacher because I couldn't quite build
up the courage to have a go at the thing
I really wanted to do that's the truth
of it so I was in teaching for a long
time 12 13 years and then I got to the
stage where I just felt I had no choice
but to give common - you get because I
knew I would forever regret it so I go
into my early 30s and thought oh you
need to just man up a bit and have a go
at it so so I did so I started by doing
a stand-up course with Chuck called
Logan Murray who's been on the circuit
for some time and has a great
understanding of comedy and is a very
good tutor he's very good at helping you
find out what's funny about you or what
you might be able to develop yeah so I
did that which was essentially an
improvised improvisation course just
like once a week for 11 weeks and then I
bit the bullet and started doing little
stand-up gigs in small pubs and clubs
you know five minutes here five minutes
there unpaid and then after a few months
you know someone might give you twenty
quid to do ten minutes and incrementally
built up until I was on the comedy
circuit where I was able to make a
living out of it and ease out of
teaching I also got was very fortunate
and I got a job writing at children's
BBC on a
- that was a really lucky break for me
in terms of being able to move away from
teaching I have lots and lots of people
who've been an inspiration to me
my dad is was the funniest human being
I'm I've ever met and my mum is very
amusing and as is my sister we laughed a
lot as a family there was a lot of
laughter in our house and often at the
expense of each other not everyone was
laughing Rik Mayall and the young ones
was a huge influence on me just the
madness of it you know my sort of the
things that make me laugh tend to be
quite extreme and frankly often puerile
but it's surprising it's it's quite hard
it's quite hard to be puro in a in an
ordered way it's a real learning process
I mean Eddie Murphy was a huge influence
on me because my dad was working in the
States when I was about 17 and I went
out after I finished my a-levels and
when I got out there
I was on my own for two months before my
sister and mum came out and I suddenly
realised my dad was actually working so
it was just me stuck in them weird time
in Virginia and I bought an Eddie Murphy
comedy tape delirious and I listened to
it for weeks on end
a lot of that tape is dated and grossly
offensive these days but there are key
elements of the storytelling it really
influenced me he does he does a routine
in that show about a barbecue or a
cookout as they call it over there and
it's just such an accurate portrayal of
of a dysfunctional family at a barbecue
it really had an impact on me and coming
from a family full of characters it
really struck a chord it made me think
can i exploit can i exploit my friends
and relatives
by you know just telling truths and then
and that's carried on into my work now I
think there's always a fundamental truth
lurking beneath any joke writing you
know if you try and make something
relatable you fail but if you if you
just tell the truth of the things you've
seen in the things that you viscerally
responded to it had a gut reaction to
that made you laugh the chances are
there's going to be quite a few people
who know why you laughed a lot of what I
do is reportage I suppose but
structuring that is is where the work
comes in the process for writing is very
different depending on what you're
writing for so I'm lucky that I get to
do stand-up and I get to write for
television and the two disciplines are
wildly different for me anyway
stand-up is a lot more straightforward
because you can go in try ideas out and
you can find out conclusively if
something has humor in it or is going to
make a group of people laugh by just
taking a germ of an idea and going to a
small comedy club and just saying it and
that appeals very much to my personality
is instant gratification it very much
appeals to me as my family would tell
you it's just like can I have it now can
we just do it now and with stand-up you
go out you're half an idea you're going
to say on a stage and if someone laughs
you think yeah okay there's something in
that writing for television is entirely
different because there's no audience
there during the whole process so you're
just hoping that you're right that this
is funny
and that it's gonna chime with people
I've just worked out certain key things
that work for me
when writing and that is one not to be
on my own and so I always get other
people in who I find funny to throw
ideas against it's sort of creating that
atmosphere really of saying a thing out
loud and seeing if it's funny and then
it's log writing for TV it's just
graft one of the few times you'll see me
irritated is if I hear someone say that
man Dame's just slapped is just a bit of
slapstick in furia it's the one thing
that drives me crazy because it isn't
just a bit of slapstick it is painfully
planned you know and everything is you
know if you saw my on the walls of my
flat when we're writing man Dana is a
wash with post-it notes having a germ of
a funny idea is very different from
making it sit within within a coherent
structure so that for me is the battle
is is making something fit together and
the only way to do that is just to keep
bashing your head against the wall it's
just to keep hitting it until it all
sits in place does that make sense but I
think how closely you stick to a script
and how much you improvise is entirely
dependent on the project because if it's
mundane then I feel entirely comfortable
at coming off the page and trying new
things out and and altering it as we go
along but if it's someone else's like
I'm in other shows I mean the show
called cuckoo I think you have to be
respectful of the of the process because
I know how much works going to my show I
don't Bowl into other people's shows you
fear my if I'm lucky enough to be on
them and start and start saying I'm
going to change this but an ideal set is
a group of people who are so comfortable
with each other that everyone's got a
voice and people can say how about this
how about we try this and in mand I'm
often you know things will come from
someone suggesting it on the set and I
love it I don't know I don't know how to
keep things spontaneous and fresh when
you're saying and repeatedly I don't
know I think you just do it but it is
often tedious that's the truth of it
that filming is often tedious often when
you do the first take of a scene for
television the crew will laugh and you
know if you when you do the rehearsal
for the crew they'll laugh and if you're
a performer like may you feed off that
and with every take that diminishes yeah
it's one of the things you just have to
learn is is to try and be consistent
it's just a slog it's just a learnt
scale I suppose and it is it's difficult
because the words start to become
meaningless it's likely anything if you
repeat any words over and over again
after a while it just sounds like you're
speaking in tongues and that's often the
case with filming yeah so it's just yeah
it's just a thing to do it the secret of
successful collaboration is just
remembering that it's everybody's that
how much everybody is invested in it I
think that's the thing to remember that
even if someone's playing a small part
in something it is significant to them
and it is part of a bigger dream of
theirs just make everyone feel important
I suppose because they are now on a show
like man down it's such an ensemble
piece it's such it's so reliant on the
interaction between the characters and
everybody feeling like they're being
funny and having fun it's one of the
first things I learned in stand-up that
Logan who run that course said you know
if you're having a good time chances are
the audience will I think it's the best
bit of advice I ever got and and if you
remember that on set if everybody is
having a good time and feeling valued
and comfortable and the chances are that
that what they what you end up watching
will be enjoyable I suppose what I enjoy
about my job is that I would be doing
this even if I wasn't being paid for it
I was a tedious show off prior to comedy
anyway so you know I do I was a drama
teacher and the kids will tell you the
kids I taught that I was an insufferable
show-off then and my friends would tell
you in pubs for many years I was always
trying to make people laugh
I can't remember Oscar Wilde's exact
quote about doing the thing that you you
know being when you find the thing that
you love to do and then someone starts
paying you for it is the dream I'm sorry
Oscar I can't remember what you said it
doesn't feel like work a lot of the time
I mean don't get me wrong often it does
the writing process feels like work but
a lot of the time it's just such a fun
and it's you know it's so great to make
people laugh or who wouldn't like you
know but if people come and watch one of
my shows and feel like they've you know
taking the day off from there from
whatever's going on in their life and
had some fun escaping it you know or
privilege
[Music]
[Music]